hello and welcome back to another video
today we're going to talk about campioni
the story kicks off in sardinia italy
godot plans to return a stone tablet
entrusted by his grandfather back to its
former owner named lucrezia zora however
erica a knight of the copper black cross
threatens him to hand over the stone
tablet calling it a grimoire yeah it's
all fun and laughs till the boar is
summoned by a rogue god named very
thragner erika heads to fight it while
the emcee runs into the rogue god godot
with no sense of stranger danger
explains that he's delivering the
grimoire to someone with that said we
back to erica who's unable to stop the
ball in time gordo rescues her before
the ball disappears erica later
discovers that gordo is delivering the
grimoire to lucrezia as such erika's
maid accompanies them to milf house
while there she reveals that the
grimoire is based on the book of
prometheus telling godot to look after
it the next day godo and erica encounter
another rogue god named mel khan who's a
bit of a chad having learned of the 10
incarnations from the grimoire godo asks
mel card to ally against viray thragana
using the grimoire godot steals verde
thranka's golden sword which by the way
is a very nice looking sword and to add
insult to injury the main man styles all
over the edge kid and french kiss the
italian chick unleashing his power and
killing very thragner becoming a
godslayer known as campione the next day
comes and godo is having a dream of
meeting pandora mother of all campiones
who hereby dubs him a campione after he
wakes up godot realizes that erika is in
his room naked she's moved to japan to
stay by his side as such she also
transfers to godot school causing him
trouble on her first day i mean come on
i guess virgins will be virgins bernardo
who comes across the new addition to his
harem a princess shrine maiden named
yuri she's with a guy who belongs to a
magic organization based in japan he
tells him that erica might want to
seduce him into joining the copper black
cross which is a valid concern because
with looks like that are we willing to
join any cross organization even a
lacrosse team that said erica brings
godot to rome upon request to meet the
representatives of the magician society
to show them his new powers by facing
him in a jewel erika didn't hold back
and try her best as well as encouraging
godot to do his best and don't hold back
either impressed the representatives
decide to entrust godot with a round
grimoire upon seeing his abilities also
he finds out that erica chose to be with
him out of true love not by orders from
a superiors a huge w for a future harem
king now back in japan we find out that
yuri has been tasked to verify the
presence of a grimoire called the
gorgonian which has been brought to
japan by godot after godo unknowingly
gives the gorgonian to yuri she lectures
him explaining that the prophecy of
princess alice foretells the gorgonian
bringing about the end of the world
known as the starless knight if obtained
by the rogue goddess athena who happens
to be in lowly form upon hearing this
godo and erica set out to find and stop
athena to buy enough time for yuri to
seal the gorgonian unfortunately athena
kisses gordo as an unexpected move to
take him out if a god doesn't kill him
he's for sure gonna have an fbi case on
his hands by the end of this series
anyway back to yuri she's approached by
a girl named liliana a knight of the
bronze black cross who's come to take
the gorgonium but yuri subordinate
arrives to rescue her from liliana and
soon after godot wakes up and erica
tells him that athena has gone after the
gorgonium erika kisses godot to transfer
information about the origin of the
gorgonian because there's no other way
to transfer information in an itchy show
now on their way yuri tries to seal the
gorgonian into shrine however athena
gets to her first although liliana comes
to aid yuri athena easily acquires the
gorgonian and transforms herself into
her goddess form as you see on the
screen the goddess form is quite well
rounded in some areas right yuri absorbs
the wind of death released from a
theater during the transformation
thankfully godot arrives in time to heal
yuri and face athena once more before
godo confronts athena erica gives him
the key to victory in the form of yeah
you guessed it a tongue fight now during
the battle gordo brings up the story of
gorgonian exposing athena's weaknesses
the battle ends when erica gives godo a
lance to pierce through athena returning
her to the lolly form and allowing her
to leave in defeat because how can you
hurt such a cute face the next day comes
and yuri wakes up from a vision she's
had about liliana discussing plans with
a campioner named sasha she keeps it to
herself hoping it was a dream and not a
vision erica challenges yuri to a
baseball match now that both girls have
a little bit of rivalry going for them
the match results in indescribable
suffering for godot as the catcher after
yuri provides godo with food erika
convinces yuri to be accompanied by
godot to buy her first cell phone
showing why erica is the best girl that
night another campione named salvatore
calls godot telling him to fight sasha
who's currently in japan to become
stronger back yuri has her bath rudely
interrupted by liliana who brings her to
sasha in his mansion now i can't tell
you if the guy looks like a vampire or a
rat but he sure looks ominous as he
tells yuri that he intends to reenact
the sacrificial ceremony of summoning a
god to ease his boredom because the old
one was crashed by salvatore four years
ago
later we see the four right subordinate
asking godot and erica to rescue yuri
from the ratman since only a campione
could face another campione as godo and
erika make it past the obstacles in the
mansion yuri voices her opinion to
liliana the godot isn't like other
campiones once godo and erika meet sasha
erika manipulates sasha into believing
that salvatore said that the elderly
should accept their age and the youth
should take over authority in response
the rat man suggests playing a game
where he releases yuri from his mansion
for which he plans to hunt the main man
down and take her back he gives them 30
minutes to run and hide classic hide and
seek there right and if they last till
sunrise then he will admit defeat after
30 minutes pass the classic game turns
into hunger games as sasha summons a
pack of wolves to chase them however
erica defeats them but then the rat man
appears and summons an army of dead
servants against her godot attacks him
by calling forth the white stallion but
sasha transforms into her werewolf form
and consumes the white stallion forcing
godot to grab yuri and retreat using the
raptor i'm not gonna lie kind of bad ass
on behalf of the old man there meanwhile
erica enters a fierce battle against
liliana when yuri tries to treat godo
for his wounds the full-ride nerd sends
yuri to persuade liliana to stop
fighting erica and defect from sasha now
together godo erika yuri and liliana all
prepare for the showdown against count
rat erika and liliana deal with the dead
servants surrounding them after kissing
erica godot brings up sasha's past
annihilating the pack of wolves a
massive plot hole but let's not question
it and let's just enjoy the action as it
was apparent to defeat the old man godot
must successfully remake his golden
sword which works out after yuri
passionately kisses him reconstructing
the sword as well as my dead boner oh
anyway sorry let's move on even though
godot defeats count douchebag the latter
still has a trick up his sleeve that's
to completely control the weather the
goat uses a goat to control thunder and
with the help of the three girls he's
able to defeat the rat once again
sunrise occurs and the old man with the
girl's name leaves while admitting
defeat now back in italy gordo is stuck
vacationing on a beach with the best
girl second girl the milf and the maid
gentleman we finally arrived at the
beach episode however the main man seems
to not enjoy as he tries to escape the
scene and he runs into athena who wants
him to come with her towards something
that has stirred up her feelings of
excitement meanwhile liliana realizes
the error of seeking salvatore's help in
dealing with the hair ion a grimoire
shaped like a stone pillar located in an
underground chamber when salvatore
slices the hair iron in half it
transforms the land's energy into a
dragon a rogue god named paseos shows up
to valiantly slay the dragon without any
concern for the consequences ignoring
liliana's pleas and cementing himself as
a douchebag bigger than lord rat
fortunately athena intervenes while
liliana takes godot away from the area
explaining to him what the cool kid aka
salvatore did when paseos pursues the
two godot calls forth the boar attack
but paseo survives using the majestic
[ __ ] godot charges at paseos however
paseo shoots godo down with an arrow to
the chest but then once again athena
comes in clutch and stops perseus from
killing godot saying the godo is much
more interesting to fight after he's
been beaten which convinces perseus to
step back until next time in another
dream goto meets pandora once again
where she notices that the ram revived
him so she encourages him to defeat
paseos when he recovers in liliana's
room liliana berates herself for her
inaction earlier liliana has made karen
a basement temps liliana to prove her
love interest in godot much to her
embarrassment godot and liliana then
tried to figure out how to encounter
perseus trump card which at this point
we all know will come down to the saliva
swapping action that said athena arrives
soon after to offer information about
paseos but this means gordo will owe her
a favor to which liliana rejects the
offer so she paralyzes him with tainted
mint tea for her to personally confront
athena
however gordo still has the strength to
make the deal with athena before she
leaves meanwhile the king of swag
prevents the other girls from reaching
godot paseo soon sends godot and liliana
a message calling for a journal a place
he considers suitable for displaying his
greatness to an audience the maid tells
liliana that the only way for godot to
defeat paseos is through as you guessed
it a kiss however godot goes off on his
own disregarding such advice when
liliana finds godo near the coliseum
perseus arrives and challenges him to a
duel in front of the audience even when
using the ball to attack godot doesn't
fare well against paseos and since godot
still doesn't have what he needs to
achieve victory liliana makes a decision
to kiss him which gives him the
necessary knowledge to defeat paseos
during the battle godot reveals that
perseus disguised himself as a greek god
for he's the persian god mithira
although godo breaks perseus bowed arrow
paseo stabs gordo with his sword but
godo uses the camel to kick him away
perseus then uses his ability to force
liliana into subservience to attack
godot but liliana manages to break free
of the spell through the power of lov
baby then she shoots paseos with a bow
and arrows allowing godot to use the
board to defeat paseos athena appears to
heal godo's wounds by kissing him before
departing i mean i'll be damned if he's
the only harem king with that much
action anyway the wholesomeness ends
when perseus is killed by a shadowy
figure with a scythe which devours him
in her serpent form it might seem like
everyone's favorite lowly did it but who
knows better stick till the end as we
move on to the next day liliana also
transfers to godot school when godo and
liliana go to yuri shrine they meet
yuri's friend anna who claims to be
chosen as godo's wife this guy just
keeps winning doesn't he then we find
out her intentions to question how
liliana and yuri each feel about gordo
this later gives the best girl erica the
opportunity to go out on a first date
with godot liliana and yuri soon realize
how they feel about godot while erika
reminisces with godot on their first
victory together against athena the
dates interrupted by enna who challenges
erica for the main girl's status however
godo tries to cease the fight but he's
instead sucked into a portal underground
to the purgatory prompting erica and
anna to jump in as well meanwhile athena
goes to look for godot in purgatory godo
meets susano in a cabin who's a pretty
chill god and also ana's guardian and
while godot was beginning to understand
who susana was before he retired to
purgatory the girls resumed their
intense fight in the mountains ena
allows her sword to fully possess and
control her which is gradually depleting
erica's energy liliana and yuri witness
a black aura filling the sky covering
the entire world when godot takes over
the fight against anna she decides to
retreat instead as eric is slowly dying
godo tries to teleport her back to earth
but ends up taking her to various places
reaching an island as erica says her
last words godo finally masters
summoning the youth from verethragna's
spirit having her ingest it through him
to save her life and give her divine
protection while trying to rescue godo
and erica liliana and yuri are
interrupted by the same scythe-wielding
serpent goddess that consumed paseos at
the shrine when ana reappears completely
merged with the sword in the form of a
god godo and erica save her but the
serpent goddess recognized as mattis
absorbs the power of ana's sword godot
recalls from susano that mantis who's
athena's mother wants to swallow the
heavens is prophesied in the gorgonian
which doesn't pertain to athena the maid
and the full-ride subordinate come to
retrieve godo as well as athena who
seems to have lost her memories after
metis previously absorbed her powers the
harem decides to stay behind and try to
buy enough time against metis to allow
godo to recharge his powers however
after the four are easily defeated metis
comes after godot who manages to revive
his powers during the fight metis
absorbs athena's powers again
transforming her into her true goddess
form to prevent the prophecy from coming
true godo receives help from each of the
four girls to expose metis weaknesses
and you know what that means don't you
just close the door behind you so that
no one walks in on this part which ends
with athena giving the last kiss after
summoning her with the gale godot was
able to achieve victory banishing the
black aura from the sky and returning
everything back to normal so this is it
for today's video if you liked the video
give it a huge thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel for more videos farewell
till next time